- Today we're talking
all about connections
that were made during our first season.
One of my favorite things to do
is connect celebrities
with everyday people,
as well as with each other.
It's always fun to see how
people relate to one another.
Like when Nicole Byer
reacted to Jason Derulo.
Check this out.
(audience clapping)
Okay here's the thing.
I said I'm going to talk about it.
Like teach me one thing.
What's one thing you could do?
I wanna be a cat.
(audience cheers and applauds)
All right.
So show us.
- Okay so (laughs).
So cats walk in a different way, right?
They walk same arm, same leg.
So it's a little different than us.
So, I mean, it's all those little.
- Oh that's odd.
- Yeah (chuckles).
- I just pictured myself.
(audience laughs)
So it's like that because we go
from two feet to four feet.
'Cause we're not like just regular cats.
We're like cat people.
So we go in, you know
from standing on two feet
into going into all fours.
So you'll be
in a conversation.
- That sounds like
junior high athletics.
- With somebody.
Yeah.
Yeah it's a lot of core.
So you'll be on two feet.
- I'm out.
- And then you'll just
be having a conversation.
- I'm out.
That's why they didn't call me.
Oh shoot.
(audience cheers and applauds)
- [Woman] Okay.
All right.
(man laughs)
- I said I was out but I'm in.
- I tried it.
It works wonders, it works wonders.
- Yeah, exactly.
I'm like if you come at a girl like that
she's like, "Yes."
- No, I don't think so.
- "I don't even know what's
happening but I'm in."
No?
- No.
If a dude just dropped on all fours
and started purring at me
I'd be like, "What is happening?"
- I would definitely start
(claps) taking my clothes off.
- I would rather a man bark at me.
I'd be like, "Oh, okay.
"Oh, okay."
- So you can see my face in that clip too.
Like what?
Like Jason Derulo is back right now.
Get him in here.
Where are you, Jason?
- What's happenin', Kelly?
- Man, I'm in a spacesuit.
So I'm havin' an awesome day.
- [Jason] Do you?
- Yes.
It's like celebrating the launch of our,
get it launch?
Yeah.
We're clever Jason over here.
- I love it (chuckles).
- At the Kelly Clarkson show.
So I have a question 'cause my friends
and family went nuts
for your cat thing.
So I mean, how did your fans react
to the cat demonstration
you did on our show?
- Oh man, it was literally hilarious.
I actually really loved the people
that had no idea what it was like.
Like (chuckles) I was
just reenacting a cat.
It was not for a movie or anything at all.
They were like, "What in
the hell is he doing?"
- I know it was so impressive regardless.
It was so impressive and controlled.
You're so muscular.
I mean, Nicole Byer's hilarious.
That whole thing was so funny.
- Hilarious.
- We're kind of celebrating some
of the best ones takes
on our show from season one
and everybody loved that one.
So is it true that you do
crazy things to celebrate
connecting with more people on Tik Tok?
- Yeah.
So every time we reach another
milestone, another million.
I do these things called mini meals
where I create like
these outlandish desserts
or like crazy meals that,
you know, we all kind of dream
about having but never
actually tasted it but
it's been pretty crazy in terms
of how good they have been.
You know a lot of people are like,
"I don't know if I would
like that amount of sugar."
Trust me.
It is unreal.
(woman laughing)
It is.
It's so good.
- I don't think I've ever actually said
that sentence in my entire existence.
I think I'm like Elf.
If there's sugar, I'm in.
- Same, same.
- Okay so you did this
crazy thing on Tik Tok.
It's a death jump on Tik Tok.
Is that what it's called?
- Yeah.
So basically,
so you drop a tissue from
the top of the stairs
and you have to like
run and try to catch it
before it touches the floor.
So (giggles).
- [Kelly] That sounds like a workout.
- Yeah.
So I mean Tik Tok
had all of these kind of
crazy challenges that you can,
you know what I'm saying?
Do what the people that you care about.
So you're not just like on Netflix
all day long playing video games.
It's just active things to do
especially during these times, right?
But (chuckles) mine ended
a little tricky you know?
I injured my knee a little bit.
It was a little painful.
- I feel like all-in.
You're one of those
people that plays sports
that's like all in.
- Oh, it's all or nothing.
I'm competitive.
- Oh man.
Me too.
Oh, it gets me in so much trouble.
Well I have been writing a lot.
I've been recording a lot and I know
a lot of artists have right now.
Have you made any new
music during the pandemic?
- I have.
A ton, a ton.
I mean, it's been incredible
to just be like I said,
it's in my own space
I have a recording facility here and man
it's just been cool from a lot
of different perspectives too.
'Cause I was just in a, you know,
I was signed to Warner brothers
for 12 years, you know?
And I'm finally free of that situation.
You know,
it was a little cantankerous
because it was four different regimes
that came in during
my (chuckles) time there.
- This is my life.
That is my life.
- And you know
when there's so many
different regimes, right?
You're just so far removed
from the people that you began with.
It's hard to like just get (claps) into a
groove into a balance,
into even a creative space
sometimes because you know,
you want to make sure that
A you're seeing eye-to-eye promotion-wise,
you're seeing eye-to-eye
creatively, you know?
So it became a real issue.
Butt now I'm free
and I've actually just released
a song called Take Your Dancing.
- [Kelly] Yeah I know, I know.
It's great.
That's awesome.
- Yeah, thank you so much.
Yeah.
I released like four songs thus far
in this pandemic.